não gosto do paseo costa farias foi esta
a frança que eu disse aos meus pais
estatal e agora joga vossa atenção para
falarmos um pouco mais sobre mim quando
era mais nova orgulhavam não ser uma
jovem conformista da minha terra
bastante conservadora estreou hoje não
costumava circular banho não tinha medo
de dar a minha opinião
participava em todas as atividades podia
e tentava ao máximo destacar da multidão
pra ser sincera nunca pensei muito e
jurídicos ainda ganhou 50 arranhões nos
joelhos tendo partes mas nunca nunca
deixar de fazer algo simplesmente por
ter medo duravam um bom desafio
mas foi durante este tempo esteve algo
em mim algo que era o único a minha
realidade que a saída agora quando a
equipe ao defender a mim foi quando
comecei a confirmar que esconder
aprendi que esconder é um hábito
progressivo a partir do momento que nós
começamos a esconder pela primeira vez
torna-se cada vez mais difícil de
conseguir dizer basta e conseguiu dizer
verdades para ter noção do comprimido é
difícil parar de se esconder
ainda hoje quando eles algumas pessoas
vinha fazer este tese o que fica disso o
verdadeiro assunto esta palestra porque
podem estar acesa perguntar por que eu
já sabia que é ter uma conversa muito
difícil com isso e eu não estava
preparada por exemplo os meus avós
pensam que estou neste palco a falar das
eleições europeias mas acredita e eu
estou aqui para falar de tudo menos nas
eleições europeias
então mas que o que eu tenho nada a
esconder durante estes anos
é verdade que eu tenha escondido durante
muito tempo é que eu sou lésbica e quem
me conhece sabe o porquê de só agora
espera que em cima e permitir que eu sou
eu nunca quis que meu grande
e com muito menos fosse associado
instantânea - cheiros humanos começam a
atribuir rótulos uns aos outros de
juizados fundem se conhecem e eu não
precisava de mais um rótulo muito menos
um rótulo que nos pés a quem os o
verdadeiramente posso vos garantir que
dentro da comunidade lgbt existem tantos
parvalhões começou os amorosos pessoas
de esquerda pessoas direita desportistas
que de princesas como medicina cuidar da
transexual cultuamos pessoas com cuidado
os produtos para consumir com as mesmas
rotas não consumimos laços humanos e
temos medo que os rótulos não joguei
pelo código de barras das sociedades e
foi esse o medo que sente por aqueles
que são grandes cidades
isto pode não parecer muito importantes
pode parecer estranho até que tenha
mantido a minha verdade durante tanto
tempo escondida mas no momento não será
sites paralisando eu sei que estou
sozinha nisso
admito fiquei muito surpreendida ao
saber que existem tantas pessoas como eu
cato imensa energia para se esconder mas
fica ainda mais aterrorizada saber que o
meu silêncio por ter tantas
consequências a nível social o facto de
um texto com disso vou ter contribuído
para o ambiente atmosférico determinação
que existe hoje em dia
pelo menos este moço minha terra estou
sendo que tenha acontecido se eu tenho
muitos amigos usavam conchas
homossexuais mas será que se eu tivesse
dito que era parte dessa comunidade que
iriam ter respeito por mim e por sempre
ser amiga de deus e repensar todos os
seus comentários
eu não sei porque eu nunca tive coragem
pra dizer que o primeiramente era que
isso afeta profundamente
há mais coisas assustadoras cá dentro do
kla fora os maiores obstáculos que
alguma vez terá que ultrapassar seus
maiores medos e inseguranças
acredito que se conseguir vencê los
eu consigo dar a minha realidade senhor
o que o pt já tem provas disso
no ano passado a fevereiro eu tive um
encontro nacional de escolas amigas de
direitos humanos e uma das atividades
conseguia falar mas no momento em que
fomos breve momento em que fomos
corajosos um dia em que chegamos à
frente tivemos a coragem pra fazer algo
que acreditem em uma das 80 pessoas que
estão aqui nesta fotografia quis
partilhar o seu
foi então que eu levantei o braço e pela
primeira vez no meio de uma sala com
pessoas que eu conhecia os anos e
pessoas que eu nunca tinha visto e nunca
mais voltei a ver eu saí pela primeira
vez em público do meu armário que
acreditei
foi um peso gigante por cima mas se eu
achava que este libertar do peso nesse
bom que aconteceu a segunda foi muito
mais importantes
quando acabei de falar outra mão
ergueu-se na sala simplesmente certas
palavras de inspiração
eu quero dizer também sou lésbica e foi
aí nesse exato momento que eu percebi
que o meu silêncio não fazia mal a
ninguém
basta de prisão um armário uma única
flor é tão mais hits e falando em
armários
gostava também desmistificar este
conceito convosco
em minha opinião todos nós temos um
armário
o meu por uma tradicional por mario aí
mas o teu o teu pode ser contata uma
criança de cinco anos que seu animal de
estimação morreu ao teu pode ser
simplesmente contar seus pais que fumam
ou qualquer uma das conversas difíceis
que nós temos que ter a nossa vida
por mais que os temas variam em
experiência de estar dentro de um
armário é universal
claro que eu poderia estar neste palco a
dar as mil e uma razões do motivo de eu
ser normal ser mais difícil do motivo
assistindo os jogos ser mais mas o que
nós fizemos em entender o difícil não é
motivo
o difícil é difícil não existe
mais difícil e não existe menos difícil
existo difícil e nós precisamos esperar
um dia a nossa dificuldade em encontrar
dificuldades todos os outros
simplesmente para nos sentirmos melhores
ou piores que os nossos irmãos então mas
por que é tão difícil se nós ser mais
na verdade é difícil que nossos armários
são interessantes
nós ficamos tão agarrados que outras
pessoas vão pensar sobre nosso indicar
dentre deus será que vamos perder um pai
mãe e um amigo
será que isto não ficar triste apontadas
nós temos tanto medo da reação das
outras pessoas a ficar preso entre deus
para terem noção os 3 surge na altura em
que era um dos perseguidos uma multi sim
na noite há muitos anos atrás
a diferença é que uma multidão de
perseguir durante uns dez 15 minutos e
scams ar mas essas conversas difíceis
podem lugar durante anos podemos nunca
será capaz de assistir mas vou partilhar
convosco três dicas que me ajudaram
imensa
peço que olhem para estas dicas com os
óculos arco-íris colocados o que eu vou
falar
normal eu ganhei mas eu tenho certeza
que essas dicas podem adaptar a qualquer
maio
a primeira dica é autêntico deixa à
beira do armadura que as pessoas sejam
verdadeiras contigo tu precisas deixar
que ele precisa mostrar que não é de
ferro
a segunda dica é direto
tu és gay diz que sugai não digas que
talvez seja gay pessoas vão ganhar certa
expectativa de tudo um dia pode durar a
terceira dica não peça desculpa nunca
peça desculpa porque o trecho mais um
ser humano extraordinário e não caba tim
basta as outras pessoas
as outras pessoas que têm que aceitar
com dois então da próxima vez que
estiverem dentro de um armário
pensei que todos nós em algum momento as
nossas vidas já estivemos por lá
nós sabemos que é difícil mas nós
precisamos de vocês aqui do lado fora
dos nossos armários suas margens em seu
lugar para as pessoas viverem e falando
nesta partir dos armários
eu estava a falar convosco de minhas e
do meu armário
eu posso dizer que tive quatro grande
fácil
a primeira é a primeira vez que fui
capaz de falar com os meus amigos me
disseram que eu era lésbica
a segunda mão da meia para faculdades
terça-feira a frase com que iniciei as
teles não gosto de apaseo el alto
paraíso falar com os meus pais e por
último o dia de hoje corresponde à
quarta fase
o diego vai permitir nunca mais voltará
esconderijo nunca sabe muito bem quando
é que deve falar deste tema de que
nossos amigos
muito menos quando está em 70 anos
estou numa terra onde ser lésbica é ser
visto como quase uma apuração e foi um
pouco o sentimento que eu tive até
conseguir falar com as duas primeiras
pessoas que orange sentem num café com
elas e disse isso
gosto do meu deus eu tive uma reação
quase instantânea
ok básica nada vai mudar
continua a ser a nossa amiga cortes
capazes quartas raparigas e foi aí
quando há sete anos que eu consegui pela
primeira vez ser o próprio que acreditem
o pescoço de cima neste dia saber que
finalmente pôde falar dos meus amores
das minhas descobertas qualquer conversa
que o maroon 5 e 17 anos quer ter
foi mesmo muito muito importante para
mim
a segunda fase corresponde à amiga para
faculdades
minha mãe é uma pessoa gosta muito de
despachar todos quanto pode ver o que
acontece
ainda não eram sete da manhã já estava
eu e minha mãe e meu pai montado na
porta da faculdade
claramente não se encontrava fechada não
acha esta manhã era um caso um caso
estranho mas o que aconteceu
assim que as portas abriram eu fui
encaminhada para a mesa da sessão
distante e foi logo e eu percebi que
estava em uma realidade totalmente
diferente
ao chegar às meias da seleção estudantes
e outros por aí com presença pessoas
apoiadas cbt nós mesmos que acreditem
por uma pessoa na minha situação vem de
uma terra antes não há um casal de
lésbicas suítes e chega à faculdade
as primeiras pessoas que encontra são
pessoas aprendam gvt foi um alívio saber
que finalmente pôde ser o próprio que
não tinha que o pior pode esconder mais
que acontece o meu primeiro dia de aulas
que também corresponde ao meu primeiro
dia do prazo
quando diz que o príncipe é exatamente
isso que não precisava vender mais sobre
quem eu era
em primeiro lugar eu não conhecia
ninguém portanto não ia ter aquela
expectativa de que as pessoas vão gostar
de mim é ser lésbica
não não conhecia ninguém exatamente como
as outras pessoas todas ninguém conhecia
eu sempre pensei se eu quero fazer
verdadeiras amizades para a vida eu não
posso mentir sobre quem eu sou
as outras pessoas também dar tudo que eu
estou a contar uma parte muito
importante da minha vida e foi o
primeiro dia de faculdade que eu pensei
eu nunca mais vou voltar a esconder
e assim foi foi todo um novo pra mim os
meus amigos aqui os filhos na faculdade
e espera levar pro resto da vida
foram as pessoas que nunca me deixaram
ir a voz sempre estiveram ao meu lado
diz
eu não preciso estar aqui em cima a
dizer nomes porque o shopping que a
emoção que todos eles o meu maior aliada
[Aplausos]
não gosto rapazes gosto raparigas dizer
isto numa véspera do natal pode ser meio
caminho andado para se ouvir o ambiente
natal e foi um cabo que eu penso em me
acontecer você sincera
no dia 22 de dezembro de 2018 seja há 11
anos atrás eu consegui ser finalmente o
próprio dos meus pais e família é
família acaba sempre por discutir nessas
ocasiões é por que é que faz os dois
quem faz o show gatica conectando o que
vai acontecer e foi um pouco com seu
coringa
estávamos em portalegre até agora grande
parte da minha família me gusta e essa
conversa prolongou se até a minha
cozinha este moço
vamos votar em si dia imaginei sentado
na minha cozinha com a minha mãe meu pai
da menina
eu não sei muito bem como é que eu tive
a coragem para dizer que queria dizer
algo mas acredita ter conseguido franks
os meus pais minha palavra para falar
foi mesmo muito importante pra mim eu
pedi a palavra ea mãe disse força fala
que eles não gosta de rapazes e
raparigas ea reação foi uma gargalhada
da minha mãe quando meu pai quando a
minha irmã e eu vou ter uma conversa
mais difícil da minha vida e eu vos
trazer riscos à vida salva novamente
foi então que minha mãe diz à filha mas
não achava que enganava alguém
seguinte umas palavras do meu pai é
simples se o for não precisa saber mais
nada só não quero é poucas vergonhas mas
estaria com o rapaz e uma rapariga
afinal a conversa mais difícil da minha
vida foi resumida rumo às gargalhadas
que os abraços site muita sorte em sair
porque país tão compreensivo e pais que
em momento algum
julgaram o plantaram desde por ser
diferentes e por isso aqui em público
estava a dizer umas palavras que nos
dizem muitos mãe
ai n muito obrigada por todo o vosso
apoio e quero que saibam que eu vos á
muito
[Aplausos]
e chega então podia de hoje a quarta e
última fase desta minha caminhada
o dia de hoje vai permitir nunca mais
voltar às quadras
é um dia que não vai abrir muitas portas
tanto a nível pessoal como a nível
profissional
mas aí também vai fechar muitas outras
que infelizmente a nossa sociedade ainda
não está preparada
as pessoas falam tão abertamente esta
questão
a sociedade tem que ultrapassar muitas
barreiras mas é hoje vocês daqui com
consciência conseguir passar a minha
palavra
a importância de sermos nós próprios eu
hoje diria do mar este rumo de nunca
mais voltar o esconderijo
isso aí vocês também vão conseguir seja
hoje seja amanhã seja no futuro
eu acredito que elas sejam coisa que
dizer basta
claramente que algumas pessoas vão ficar
desapontados mas esse é um problema
delas não é um problema voz aquelas são
expectativas delas sobre quem você chão
são as vossas aquelas são histórias
deuses só por quem você chão não é vossa
e única história que importa é a
história que tu estás a viver
obrigada
[Aplausos]